Freak bitches.
Oh look at this fucking photograph.
There is a lion that is hugging a bear and the lion has a tear rolling down his
face and the bear has a tear rolling down his face and it says,
Ban,
Ban the bear hunt.
They are all cecil.
Save New Jersey barriers.com.
Oh my God.
First makes me want to punch somebody in the face.
What kind of fucking crazy person living,
living some weird bubble made this billboard and spent actual human money on it.
Yeah,
I dunno.
This fantasy land if they haven't seen.
Okay.
They have a giant problem with bears in New Jersey.
And this is,
this is this facts behind this.
First of all,
a student from rutgers was fucking killed by a bear right outside of rutgers.
He,
that photograph student took this photo of a bear just before it killed them.
Um,
I was talking to a guy who is,
who knows rangers out there and they're telling people not to hike.
They have so many Goddamn bear in New Jersey.
And why do they have so many bear?
Because they didn't have a hunt for them.
So these God damn things,
they got overpopulated and they have now they're,
they're entering into residential neighborhoods and these,
look at this fucking video.
Bear fight far rockaway,
New Jersey,
August 14th of 2014.
These bears are duking it out.
These are big black bears like seven foot bears,
400 plus pound bears,
and they are going to war in this guy's front lawn.
These are huge.
I mean if you were an Alberta and you saw one of these bears coming in,
you'd be like,
Ooh,
that's a trophy bear.
That's a giant bear.
That's hundreds of pounds of meat for the grill.
And these bears are in this guy's lawn.
I mean this isn't a,
this isn't some crazy rural,
you know,
Akins living in the middle of the nowhere.
No,
this jersey,
this thing just knocked over a lamp post and now it's colliding with these
garbage pails.
Watch this.
They come.
They're fighting over territory by the way.
That's created by garbage.
That's what the territory is.
They attack people's garbage and these two bears,
they bite each other and then they do get out.
Look at the size of these bears know these are huge,
right?
Well that's,
that's why.
Okay,
so maybe there was before there's houses that was perfect bear habitat,
but guess what?
There's houses now.
So that means we have to control the bare numbers that's hunting.
Well,
here's another part of the problem.
These bears weren't here 30 years ago.
These bears are overpopulating and moving into these neighborhoods and they're
doing it because they know that people live there and it's a steady supply of
food.
So the cancer thing,
and I get there probably is linked to cancer,
but they've pulled back on the red meat in general.
They're not sure about it,
but the thing is,
and I think the study is skewed because you talk about cancer and Ph.
Okay?
You know,
grass fed beef has a neutral Ph,
corn fed,
grain fed beef,
that Ph goes up and we know that cancer thrives in an acidic environment
environment.
You know,
and you know,
there's other things that the cows that have a high acid guts basically is what
it is.
They're more prone to acidosis,
which,
which needs more medication.
You need antibiotics.
Um,
and it's also a prime harbor for Ecolab.
The uh,
I'll,
I'll find a stat for you,
but the Akola it's,
I think it was 6 million,
300,000 milligrams per.
I'll look that up.
I'll chime back in and you guys talk.
I,
that's an important.
Yeah,
go ahead and look that up.
But um,
it's a very important point I think you're making about,
um,
about how these animals that are unhealthy,
it's kind of unhealthy to eat an unhealthy animal.
That seems logical.
Ah,
so this is now we're talking cells per gram of meat.
Okay.
So in your grain fed the count of Ecolab,
the grain fed and the count will be coli,
6 million,
300,000 cells per gram in the grass fed 20,000.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Why is nobody doing this?
Why is nobody just leave it here?
Just hit them a little bit.
Do look away.
Because most times when you look away they think a book just flat hand on the
center of the chest and just shoved it over the chest.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That does make sense.
But when I work with a punch as well with the.
Yeah,
but you have more space with a poem on this distance.
This is much shorter than this.
This is like an extra 15 percent,
which will make a lot of difference.
That's that distance.
That's a very good point.
Like another five or six inches at least.
Listen,
that's why I never understood.
Nobody's throwing palm strikes.
Now that left Hook,
right?
Straight combination,
In boxing,
right.
It's a dump combination.
If you really think about it,
if there's a short left hook.
I'm way too close with my straight punch.
It has no power.
I can't stretch my arm,
but if I do a palm strike and then a straight punch,
now I got space for my straight punch.
It's much harder.
So why is nobody doing that?
Now?
I do closed lines.
I posted a thing on facebook like a year ago when I hit a bag with a
clothesline.
Dude,
I don't think people can imitate me.
My weight with a kick like that,
they can kick.
And then I said,
okay,
now I show a clothesline.
Is she the back folding or out?
My whole arm is the courageous thing you can block with.
Tim had tried to block whatever you want.
If I closed line,
you have you stand still.
It goes straight through everything.
I guarantee you and knock you out.
Why is that?
Why is it close on so path?
It is so powerful because you can really lock it up.
Don't stretch your arm because if you miss time and you hit your,
you got to hyperextend,
but you can drag your whole body weight in there because you like it and your
legs are planted on the ground.
Yeah,
you're getting all that hip torque and it is such a powerful strike and also
with the clinch when even when they stand like this,
if I do this,
it loops around to defense and it hits the back of their head still the legal
part,
right?
Because it's outside the Mohawk.
Well,
he's in the back of the head.
Standing never seems to get like in boxing they get penalized for punching the
back of the head.
People say no rabbit punches,
but when you think about a head kick,
a lot of head kicks,
especially the ones that go over the shoulder there,
there the back of the head and it's,
and it's legal and that's why they're effective and that's why it was so
effective with me with,
uh,
with,
with pancreas,
I hid behind the ear.
If you look at Mike Tyson's fights,
you know,
I don't know how he did it,
but he did it.
He was always the shorter guy.
But if you see him hooking somebody,
he hits almost the back of the head.
He just got very short hooks.
Now the body,
it's ready for impact from the front,
from the side,
because you're used to it.
Well,
if you can see the punch coming,
the behind,
I always tell people,
just do it with the palm.
Just do this to the back of your head and see what happens.
Like just me doing this.
It's all ready to go.
You're not ready for that.
So you can already imagine if you go hit as hard as you can be here.
It's a sweet,
the sweet bunch.
Again,
understand nobody's doing it the head that much more dangerous.
Oh,
do this,
do this.
But I mean,
is it that much more digital than just behind the ear?
Just do that.
Oh yeah.
Right.
And I was down here do and sound like
would do platform where cry would demonstrate how to do stuff for other
hairdressers and people.
And I went to a,
uh,
not the viper room,
one of those clubs and this pretty woman comes up to me and says,
uh,
are you a musician?
And I'm like,
yeah,
but I'm kind of about to say,
but I live in Canada and uh,
you know,
and she goes,
well,
my husband's putting together a band and you got to meet him.
His name is Andy Mccoy and Eddie Mccoy wouldn't mean much to a lot of people.
But to somebody who was really into like motley crue and stuff like that,
he was in a band called Hanoi rocks that was kind of started that movement.
I'm like,
Whoa,
shit,
I'm going to be famous.
I'm going to be rich and famous.
Not knowing that although metal edge told me that this guy was a big deal,
he was just to get a musician,
but I had to a 20 year old from Winnipeg,
so oh my God,
I'm going to be in a huge fucking band.
So I go and I meet them.
We go to his house in Woodland Hills and I actually,
I've been here four times.
There was that time that I flew home to Winnipeg and they flew me back down
because they were going to get me singing in their band.
I'm like 20 years old.
This guy is like famous to me.
Right.
So I get down there and that shit is not all that organized.
You know what I mean?
Like something's not making a lot of sense.
And then around day two I figured out,
okay,
it's because everyone's on heroin.
And it started.
We had smoked some pot,
which in Winnipeg,
in Manitoba we called that dope,
you want to smoke some dope?
So like,
sure.
It was like,
so it goes,
do you do dope?
I'm like,
yeah,
I just smoked it with you like 20 minutes ago.
No,
like,
and then before I knew it he had injected me with heroin conversation sorta
happened.
I was trying to be a,
not super uncool but like not saying yes I want to do heroin and then four days
went by like literally just shooting up for days and then I just about ms.my
plane home and so I had a girl and a and a home and a job and all those kinds of
things that I'm kind of looking at like the plane ticket and I know it's like
okay,
if I get a cab in the next two hours I'll get the plane,
I'll get home and whatever.
And he's like,
well just,
you know,
and you're not even thinking.
It's like barely even there and somewhere along the line I was just like,
don't worry about it.
Just fine.
You don't have to go get on the plane.
I probably got $100 to my name and if I didn't get on that play and not have no
job,
no girl,
I'd be a heroin addict with no money in woodland hills with a guy who's doesn't
have his shit together.
I think in the years since he's got his shit together,
I haven't seen him since then and uh,
I've made myself go and I was sick for two or three days and I realized like
literally that second in time if I don't convince myself to get on that plane,
my whole life is fucking ruined.
Whoa.
Yeah.